all right so this deep state that we
have been warning you about now for a
long time as going all out now this week
two separate major leaks from Robert
Muller's off the rails political
witch-hunt are now revealing the special
counsels obsessive determination to set
a perjury trap for president Trump now
the New York Times released a list of
questions that Robert Muller allegedly
wants Donald Trump to answer these
questions are all open-ended they're
patently frankly ridiculous and they are
designed to trap the president into
committing perjury now some of the
questions even targeted the president's
own thoughts what does the president
think about James Comey what does the
president think about the sessions
recusal what does the president think
about the special counsel so let me get
this straight
is Robert Muller now the thought police
is it now we illegal in the United
States of America for a sitting
president of the United States to have
private thoughts according to the
Washington Post Robert Muller has now
even threatened the president with a
subpoena if he refuses just to sit down
for an interview I'll forget that Robert
Muller was tasked with investigating
Russian collusion and forget it after 50
weeks where they have found zero
evidence of any wrongdoing by the
president this is now a political
takedown of the person that you chose to
lead this country now should we be
surprised
well this investigation is being
conducted by some of the same people who
were totally complicit in using Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for Russian
lies you know the unverified steeled
dossier as actual evidence to obtain a
FISA warrant to spy on an American a
trump campaign associate in the lead-up
to an election in other words the FBI
used Democratic campaign material during
an election lied and passed it off as
legitimate evidence in order to get a
FISA warrant from a FISA judge to spy on
the Trump campaign that dossier was
never verified never corroborated has
now been debunked and they now literally
they never told the judge that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC whose finances she
was controlling paid for it it is
outrageous and this is the United States
of America
now remember here's the
who if you will of robert muller who he
hired to lead the Special Counsel
investigation what do we see a bunch of
big-time Democratic donors including who
the new york times referred to as his
pit bull Andrew Weissman he's given
thousands of dollars to Democrats and
remember we have disclosed Weissman's
very aggressive tactics they have caused
multiple overturns and wrongful
convictions ruining countless lives at
Anderson accounting Merrill Lynch
elsewhere and let's not forget that
Trump hating FBI lovebird Peter struck
he helped author Hillary Clinton's
exoneration before overseeing the
interview months later and of course
struck was so blatantly biased he was
removed from the investigation of Robert
Muller but then you have Robert Muller's
other top deep state Democrats they
remain today now just a few minutes
trump attorney former New York City
Mayor Rudy Giuliani will be here to give
us an exclusive interview to discuss
whether or not the president should ever
agree to an interview with this band of
many Trump hating sycophants of Hillary
Clinton
now Giuliani will also help break down
the brand-new charges and changes on
Trump's legal team including tonight's
breaking news now just hours ago the
White House announced that Ty Cobb will
be retiring at the end of may and
powerful longtime Washington attorney
Emmett flood will join his legal team
we'll have more on that in a minute but
first we have a shocking story to bring
you revealing the toll that this ongoing
witch-hunt is taking on real people who
have realized and frankly anyone who has
ever worked with President Trump or on
his campaign former Trump campaign
communication adviser Michael Caputo he
recently told the Senate Intel committee
their investigation has had a
devastating financial impact on him and
his family forced him to sell his home
because he's incurred over $100,000 in
legal bills and during the closed-door
session Caputo told the Senate committee
quote what America needs is an
investigation of the investigators I
want to know who's paying for the spies
work and coordinating this attack on
President Donald Trump I want to know
who cost us so much money who crushed
our children who forced us out of our
home all because you lost an election I
want to know because GD you to hell
despite real-life consequences from
Caputo and others associated with the
Trump campaign and the Trump presidency
with literally no evidence of collusion
after months and months and months of
multiple investigations
you still have your mainstream media
they're pushing forward almost in unison
their effort to aid and abet the deep
state with this non-stop 24/7 obsessive
negative Russia Russia Russia stormy
stormy stormy coverage and in the
meantime ignoring every major Trump
accomplishment now take a look at some
of this week's coverage that is an
example so the New York Times is out
tonight with a list of 49 questions that
Special Counsel Robert mola reportedly
wants to ask President Trump in the
Russia investigation which means as of
tonight we've now got a list of 49
things that Robert Moeller wants to know
from the president about the Russia
investigation you're saying the
president United States goes into the
Situation Room to get away from the
chiefs of staff and call him well I am
told by one friend of the presidents
that on more than one occasion he has
been called by the president from the
Situation Room yep what this tells us is
that the subject of collusion despite
what you hear from the White House
despite the fact that the president 15
times a day tweets out that says there
was no collusion it tells us that Robert
Muller is not done with the collusion
question sources tell CNN president
Trump's lawyers are preparing for a
showdown with Robert Muller that's over
the special counsels warning that he
could issue a subpoena forcing the
president to appear before a grand jury
the best argument is a Justice
Department cannot charge a sitting
president he will not be a sitting
president all his life one day he will
walk outside one glorious day he will
walk outside of those 16 acres at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue and he will could be
then charged with a crime there is so
much evidence in the public domain of
collusion we don't know if whether any
of it rises to a criminal level but
there is simply no question that the
Trump administration welcomed Russia's
help in sabotaging Hillary Clinton's
campaign
there's none that's why you need a deep
state that's why that's why you need
people whose commitment is not to the
person but it's to the process and the
law yeah well forget about all of
president Trump's historic
accomplishments for example on the
Korean Peninsula
we're actually talking
d nuclearization forget about all these
developments look what the Prime
Minister of Israel did yesterday there
is a nuclear program in Iran or the
booming economy record low unemployment
in 14 states in the United States now
record low unemployment for women in the
workplace Hispanics and African
Americans record lows and the media
wants you to believe the White House is
in shambles
not so but you know better and that's
why according to a brand new Rasmussen
poll President Trump has a higher
approval rating in his second year than
former President Obama and by the way
you're not going to hear that in the
mainstream media instead the chances are
you'll probably see this guy Michael
avenatti a lawyer for stormy Daniels
according to News Buster's avenatti was
on fake news CNN a whopping 59 times in
less than two months and finally tonight
we turn to the Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein as we speak
he continues to Stonewall congressional
efforts to do their job and get to the
bottom of multiple serious issues
including FISA abuse spying on American
citizens not telling the truth to a FISA
Court presenting political information
not telling the court presenting
unverified uncorroborated information
paid for by Hillary Clinton and the DNC
by a foreign national lies from Russia
oh I thought Russian collusion and
foreign nationals influencing our
elections were bad now earlier today
President Trump tweeted quote a rigged
system they don't want to turn over
documents to Congress what are they
afraid of
why so much weird acting why such
unequal justice at some point I will
have no choice but to use the powers
granted to the presidency and get
involved and breaking today Fox News has
learned that some lawmakers still have
not been given adequate access to the
documents they have subpoenaed and been
requesting to the House Judiciary
Committee in the house oversight
committees rod Rosenstein if you have
nothing to hide regarding the
department's FISA practices why not
release them why not release all the
documents let the American people see it
if you have nothing to hide on the
handling of the Clinton investigation
hand over the documents nothing to hide
on Russia
illusion investigation hillary paying
Christopher steel funneling money
through a law firm Russian lies to
manipulate the American people to get a
warrant to spy on a trump campaign
associate hand it over tonight every
single American needs to be asking just
what is rot Rosenstein hiding